hey what's up y'all MKBHD here welcome
back to another video this one a little
bit outside of the usual Studio element
as you can immediately tell uh that of
course usually means I'm in a hotel room
and that's true again this time I'm in
California um and I'm out here because
this week is the ultimate frisbee Beach
World Championships it's like a 5day
long tournament it's super countries all
over the world flying in here to compete
and I will be competing I'm playing on
mixed Team USA so
pretty incredible actually this is a
opportunity of a lifetime and it's been
one of my goals for basically my entire
Ultimate Frisbee career to play on a
Team USA and represent the country in a
world championship so pretty awesome
that it's happening so shout out to that
team uh and also for letting me get over
here to this hotel to also talk a little
bit of tech because you know I couldn't
resist there's a random Apple event this
week it's the Night Before Halloween and
they're talking new Max new M3 Max and
uh
well we got to talk about it see the
thing is in the tech World a lot of
times you know obviously these product
announcement events are super exciting
but sometimes the story behind like
leading up to the event is just as
exciting as the actual thing being
announced so in the in the Arc of
technological progress hopefully I'm
doing this on the right side usually
there's a little bit of an arc like a
really really fast explosive beginning
adoption phase and then things sort of
even out and become mature
and stable and every every piece of tech
goes through this Arc at different times
you know with the smartphone World we're
at like the flat part most of the time
iPhone 15 is just a little bit better
than iPhone 14 which was a little bit
better than 13 but we did have to go
through that explosive growth to get
here and then there's other stuff like
folding phones maybe that are just at
the beginning or electric cars we see
all kinds of first and second gen
electric cars now so those are clearly
at the beginning of that Arc where all
the early adopter and bleeding edge Tech
stuff is going on and so I bring all
this up because with our computers it's
actually not quite as straightforward as
we think they've actually kind of had an
interesting curve I think we all agree
that computers laptops very mature but
what Apple did with apple silicon when
they announced Apple silic their own
integrated chips that they would be
making and designing in-house to replace
the Intel stuff that was in MacBook Pros
and Macs before they made this really
big dent in the graph they made a big
leap that you don't usually see so
they're very very stable with all these
Intel machines for a while and then this
big jump up to Apple silicon Max and
these things were a hit I I love mine
I'm I'm in this hotel right now with my
M1 Max MacBook Pro and you would think
this is one of those things that I
usually like to stay on the bleeding
edge and keep the latest and greatest
stuff in my Arsenal but I haven't
upgraded this in years because I haven't
needed to it's been amazing a lot of
creators that I know use these laptops
M2 came out after it was an Improvement
but kind of back to being like a
reasonable 30% still a big jump but like
a 30 to 40% bump in CPU and GPU so we
had this stability for a while a huge
bump and then sort of leveling back off
but then on top of all of that there's
actually been a couple other
announcements that have been sort of
intriguing of other silicon
manufacturers actually catching up this
is all I'm speculating a little bit
because I haven't tried some of this
stuff but there was a recent Qualcomm
announcement where they showed off some
new Chips they're working on that they
are claiming has performance that's Way
Beyond what M2 already offers so all of
that is the backdrop for this event that
I'm about to watch where we kind of
wonder if Apple's going to be able to
give us some reasons to continue to buy
new Macs new Mac sales have not been
growing as much of they' as they've
wanted and they really want to give us
new reasons to so I'm curious not just
about the actual products that they're
about to announce but the story and the
convincing that they have to do around
the new products I'm very confident that
they'll be very technically impressive 3
nmet chips Etc but I'm about to sit down
and watch the event but that's just the
backdrop to what we're about to get
let's
see good evening and welcome to Apple
Park all right so that event
was interesting it it was it was about
what we expected but again sometimes the
stuff around the event is more
interesting the event itself so uh we
got what we expected it was a pretty
short event they got right to the Chase
and M3 M3 Pro and M3 Max are the new
Chips they're all 3 nanometer chips too
which is awesome and then we got the
machines that they're in so there is a
new Macbook Pro 14in and 16in which have
these new chips and they refresh the new
iMac now there are some new abilities
with these chips right there are some
subtle things that you may or may not
take advantage of like improved mesh
shading or now there's Hardware
accelerated R chasing for applications
that take advantage of that maybe you're
generating three new models or you're
doing after effects work or working in
Maya or something like that but
something sneaky that they did was in
the general broad performance stuff that
they talked about they of course showed
their usual graphs but they almost
always verbally compared the M3 family
to the M1 family of chips not M2 and you
know that obviously makes sense they're
trying to make the improvements look as
large as possible M2 Chip is only 2
years old so the fact that they're 50%
better in some stuff 60% better than M1
is amazing but if you look at comp
comped to M2 most of the numbers were
more in the 10 to 15 to 20 25% range
better than M2 as far as raw performance
but again it's going to depend on your
workflow I'm just thinking all right
this is about what we expected I'm going
to have to test the machines to figure
out what battery life is like and what
general performance and the stuff I do
is like I do video editing they showed
other workflows like DNA sequencing and
like building applications and coding
and all all kinds of stuff I don't do
but generally modest update now this
whole time I'm watching this event I'm
thinking okay I probably don't need to
upgrade right I mean I have this M1 Max
MacBook Pro it's been great so what
machines are they going to put this new
M3 family of chips in so they introduced
them to us and there are some new
Macbook Pros and a new iMac the iMac is
easy and probably actually where that M1
comparison makes the most sense it's the
same thin colorful iMac just with the
new M3 same price beautiful easy simple
upgrade but MacBook Pros uh a little bit
different they first of all got rid of
the 13-in MacBook Pro with touch bar
totally fine with me good riddance
honestly it's now just a 14-in and 16-in
MacBook Pros the 14-in you can get the
base M3 or M3 Pro or M3 Max and then the
16 in you can get M3 Pro or M3 Max and
they also
introduced a new
color uh called space
black a matte
anodized
aluminum black MacBook
Pro and uh
well I might I might want to upgrade I
don't I don't need it though I don't
need it but I kind of I might want to
upgrade I don't need it I don't need it
I definitely don't need it you know
clearly Apple's very clever about this
stuff they know that if they just do the
new chip then maybe not as many people
will upgrade but if you want to know
that you have the new one it's the most
classic apple thing is they give it a
new look and then you know you have the
new one just by looking at it and so
this this black one it speaks to me they
talked about it in the event as having a
special anodized coding to prevent
getting lots of fingerprints I'm very
curious about seeing that in person we
have some footage here ideally that I'm
I'm showing you right now of actual
inperson looks at that new matte black
MacBook Pro I'm calling it matte black
it's supposed to be space space black or
whatever but I'm calling it matte black
and you know I have a black dbrand skin
on my MacBook Pro right now it does pick
up a little bit of fingerprints and you
can see that so I'm very interested if
that will actually hide fingerprints
we'll see and the other thing that I was
actually curious about is uh they're
going to ship a new iMac but they just
sent the iPhone to USB type-c so are
they also going to switch all these
silly accessories like the trackpad and
the keyboard to finally be USB type-c so
we can slowly start getting rid of
lightning everywhere but they didn't
it's still lightning trackpad lightning
keyboard so that upgrade will have to
see another day so those are just some
nuggets for you but I think generally
the thought here is what Apple's trying
to do is make this upgrade seem as large
as possible even though really people
who have M1 and M2 likely won't have to
upgrade if you have an M1 Max how big of
an upgrade is M3 Max really going to be
it will depend on if you're pushing your
current M1 Max to its limit limit and
most people aren't you know who you are
if you are pushing it to its limit I'll
put it that way um I am currently you
know I'm going to edit this video this
4K video from the Canon R5 I'm going to
chop it up on Final Cut Pro on the
laptops and it's going to break a sweat
a little bit I already know but it's
going to export in a a handful maybe 25
minutes and then it's down to my
internet connection that's usually my
biggest obstacle so I don't actually
need to upgrade but the really
impressive part is for the people who
are actually maxing out these machines
lighting up all the cores you know they
have a new maximum of 128 gigs of
unified memory on the M3 Max so people
who are really pushing these machines to
their limits are going to have even more
amazing machines to go out and do their
3D rendering their DNA sequencing all
the stuff that they're doing and pack
that machine up and take it on the go
which is ultimately what this is about
also this was so random but at the very
end at the very end did you catch at the
end of the key keynote that little
message with
text the keynote ends they fade to black
and on a black background with white
text they say this event was shot on an
iPhone
and wow I did not see that coming I
watched the event fully believing that
this this was probably shot on regular
cameras cuz there's also like drone
shots and CGI and all sorts of added
effects and it's colored beautifully and
I don't know where the microphones are
again I have so many questions I want
I've wanted to see behind the scenes of
an Apple keynote so badly for years but
more than any other one I've wanted I
want to see the behind the scenes of
this one so that I just I'm just putting
that out into the
universe amazing amazing production I'll
say stay tuned for a review of these
machines if you want to see real footage
of the matte black MacBook Pro and all
this new stuff get subscribed below I do
plan on getting my hands on that stuff
and reviewing it when it comes out but
this just been my uh first look and
impression
thanks for watching catch you in the
next one go USA
peace